[Musica]
buon pomeriggio a tutti benvenuti sono
paolo
sono molto contento di essere qui oggi
per parlarvi di una cosa che ormai devo
dire sulla bocca di tutti ma anche molto
insidiosa le cripto valute
permettetemi però di iniziare facendo
che qualche domanda
potete rispondermi con una semplicissima
alzata di mano
chi di voi ha mai pensato un giorno di
informarsi su cosa fosse una cripta
valuta un bitcoin
costituito un purtroppo in sala
chiedi voi ha mai pensato un giorno di
acquistare un beat coin una cripta
valuta
meno mani
chi di voi possiede già oggi un bitcoin
un accredito valuta e le mani quando
faceva la luce sono pochissime
il tema delle cripto valute da una
grandissima occasione almeno dal mio
punto di vista di osservare cercare di
capire il backstage della finanza cosa
c'è dietro alle quinte del palcoscenico
degli strumenti finanziari
per certi versi
cercare di esplorare la differenza che
c'è tra la realtà apparente quelle
autentiche un po come ci hanno insegnato
tutte le novelle di pirandello un po il
3 d'union di tutto il gli interventi del
pomeriggio questo è il mio deposito dove
detengono una quota di bitcoin era da
tanto tempo che sentivo parlare di
cripto valute e mi ero incuriosito
perché apparentemente erano strumenti
molto diversi da quelli che ho
incontrato fin ormai è più di 30 anni di
lavoro in banca poi avevo amici
conoscenti che cominciavano a chiedermi
cosa devo fare a paolo compro mi informo
a quel punto mi sono deciso ho detto
voglio approfondire
partiamo allora dalla genesi
i bitcoin o le cripto valute sono una
moneta
una strategia di investimento
uno strumento finanziario per diventare
ricchi in poco tempo
andiamo per ordine
le cripto valute sono una moneta
se finita questa chiacchierata vi invita
sì tutti a prendere un caffè in quel
bellissimo chiosco che c'è fuori di
fronte al museo per parlare se vi è
piaciuto il mio incontro se sono stato
utile e volesse offrire un caffè pagando
in bitcoin
potrei
c'è qualche paese in cui potrei farlo
e per inciso se sapete quanti caffè
potrei comprare con bitcoin 40.000 chi
mi darebbe il resto
ora capite bene che il tema non è per
nulla scontato anche perché ci sono
produttori di beni e servizi che già
oggi la mia opinione un po anche con una
logica di marketing
dichiarano di accettare già oggi in
pagamento bitcoin e o altri tipi di
credito valute ma questo dipenderà
naturalmente
dall'atteggiamento che avranno le
autorità di vigilanza anche perché
badate bene le cripto valute per certi
versi hanno preso in contropiede anche
la normativa una cosa dal mio punto di
vista è certa i pagamenti digitali
stanno sostituendo sempre più contante
nei giovani ma dopo il covi non solo
questo sicuramente un aspetto pensando
alla moneta che potrebbe accelerare la
valutazione da parte degli stati di
adottare monete digitali e badate bene
non ha detto solo tritolo
secondo appunto le cripto valute sono
una strategia di investimento
ma innanzitutto cos'è una strategia di
investimento qui sono molti studenti
facciamoci aiutare da wikipedia in
finanza una strategia di investimento è
un insieme di regole
comportamenti o procedure che guidano la
selezione di un portafoglio di
investimento da parte di un
risparmiatore in sostanza
come e dove investiamo i nostri soldi se
l'è cripto valute sono una strategia di
investimento dipende dalle prospettive
c'è qualcuno in finanza
che le sta definendo già
cosiddetto strumento alternativo
un bene rifugio alla stregua dell'oro
ora capite bene che definire già oggi in
questo contesto affermazioni graditi che
mi sembra un po molto azzardato anche
perchè pensate che la sim nicholas taleb
saggista molto esperto di analisi dei
contesti di incertezza e quello che ha
declinato la teoria del cigno nero
ha cambiato idea
inizialmente
considerava le cripto valute come
un'assicurazione rispetto al governo del
denaro
poi recentemente ha detto che non
valgono nulla anzi sono uno schema ponzi
cioè una truffa
quindi se un saggista professore di
cambridge esperto cambia idea forse
qualche domanda dovremmo farcela ancora
anche noi
terzo tema
le cripto valute sono uno strumento
finanziario per guadagnare tanti soldi e
poco tempo
la risposta è no
quando noi non conosciamo le cose o le
conosciamo molto poco il rischio
nell'affrontare un acquisto un
investimento è altissimo se poi chi si
approccia questi investimenti anche poco
scarsa competenza finanziaria
il rischio è estremamente pericoloso
anche perché creano nella testa di
queste persone l'abbiamo visto
all'inizio di questa di questo evento
l'illusione
di guadagnare tanto in breve tempo e
senza rischio
ora capite bene che questo è una
situazione che genera un sistema
generale molto pericolosi in più noi non
abbiamo ancora certezza di quello che
potrebbe succedere diciamo che lo
spettro molto ampio anche perché abbiamo
chi le sta mettendo al bando c'è la vita
te la cina e quindi ne ha azzerato il
valore chi sta cercando qualche stato di
capire se si possono introdurre come
moneta nazionale
diciamo che questo primo periodo nelle
cripto valu questa prima fase di
adolescenza preadolescenza delle cripto
valute ha avuto grandissima turbolenza
tutto questo però ha generato un
grandissimo clamore mediatico
tant'è che a un certo punto questo
clamore mediatico non macroeconomia cioè
l'amore mediatico ne è aumentato in modo
incredibile il valore anzi di un certo
punto sembrava che questo valore fosse
inarrestabile e in più ha indotto quelle
persone di cui vi parlavo prima
tendenzialmente con la competenza
finanzia faccio fatica ancora io parlare
di questi strumenti poco per esempio
molto scarsa di voler partecipare a
questa festa di essere parte di questo
fenomeno
un fenomeno che non è ancora né
regolamentato né classificato e quindi
cosa genera genera due fenomeni
diventano una leggenda oggi il bitcoin
inflitto permettimi su una leggenda
quantomeno nella percezione di alcuni di
noi
secondo sono alla portata di tutti con
un'app l'altro giorno mentre rimane che
rientrava da milano reggio emilia le ho
sentite pubblicizzata la radio radio o
sennò qualche call center o sui nostri
social che ce lo propongono come se
fossero l'investimento più semplice al
mondo quindi sono alla portata di tutti
quando un fenomeno economico diventa di
massa o socio economico di mente di
massa è importante chiedersi chi ci
guadagna che non ci guadagna chi ci
guadagna poco e soprattutto chi ci perde
la persona che vedete la vostra sinistra
nella slide credo non ha bisogno di
presentazione lloyd mask più volte è
intervenuto sul tema cristo valute
l'altra persona che vedete nella slide e
il mio idraulico che una mattina
nel bar a san polo d'enza piccolo
paesino della provincia di reggio emilia
dove io risiedo
mentre beve caffè con lui sapendo il
mestiere che faccio mi dice ciao paolo
come stai la settimana scorsa ho
comprato bitcoin cosa ne pensi
si punta ad essere la breve vita ho
capito che il bitcoin stava diventando
un fenomeno di massa ma anche un
problema di massa
non semplice da gestire anche perché di
fondo il concetto della domanda da
chiedersi è ma chi governa veramente
bitcoin o la cripta valute
siamo sicuri che riusciamo ad evitare
una bolla speculativa
ci siamo fatti tutte le domande affinché
noi siamo in grado di fare un
investimento coerente rispetto al nostro
profilo di rischio alla nostra idea ma
torniamo al perché ho vestito in bitcoin
avevo bisogno di capire io anche per la
mia professione e allora esplorato anche
tre temi 1 o cercato di capire le
differenze tra le varie critto valute
2 ho cercato di capire chi erano gli
intermediari e come ci negoziavano 3
qual era la tecnologia sostegno la block
c'è forse la bruxelles è la novità più
grande ma
torniamo sempre al tema che cos'è la
bruxelles
facciamoci aiutare sempre di wikipedia
la block cei letteralmente catena di
blocchi e una struttura da condivisa è
immutabile
vuol dire che non può mai più cambiare
nel tempo è definita come un registro
digitale le cui voci sono raggruppate in
blocchi concatenate in ordine sono
immutabili e cronologicamente definite
la cui integrità e garantita dall'uso
della crittografia quindi di fatto la
blow chain è lo strumento che permette
alla cripta valuta di vivere in che modo
in modo
decentralizzato
decentralizzato significa che negli
scambi non c'è un intermediario ma anche
ad esempio
significa che non c'è ancora un ente la
banca centrale europeo la fede americana
che possono regolamentare
la negoziazione o la diffusione di
queste monete
capite che è uno scenario molto di
drappi soprattutto per il mondo della
finanza del mio
ecco ma siamo sicuri che
non avere enti che regolano e monitora
no questo fenomeno sia una cosa buona
otterrete hicks puntualmente la
conoscete
questa è la frase che ha pronunciato
l'attuale nostro presidente del
consiglio mario draghi allora il 2012
presenta la bce e vi sembrerà strano ma
questa frase ha salvato l'italia se non
dal fallimento del commissariamento ora
capite bene che
l'intervento o la gestione di un ente
che possa indirizzare comportamenti da
questo punto di vista per alcuni è molto
importante per altri alla limitazione
della libertà individuale economica e
come sempre siamo a costi benefici
dobbiamo decidere qual è il costo è
quella il beneficio quale prevale come
sempre capire qual è la realtà apparente
rispetto a quella autentica
vado in conclusione
l'ultima parte della mia analisi della
mia ricerca
si è concentrata su
come acquistare bitcoin e dove metterli
no prima di te li porti a casa te li
metti in garage
il fai da te anche in questo caso è
pericolosissimo
allora ho scoperto che la garanzia di
possesso
la cripto valuta si basa su una coppia
di chiari una pubblica e una privata
laddove quella privata ea esclusivo
possesso del singolo cioè singolo sulla
dimentica in un momento di amnesia o un
hacker informatico della ruba il giorno
dopo lui avete
zero
capisce bene quanto è importante
informarsi bene ed è per questo che io
alla fine torna all'inizio ho deciso di
investire con un cast o rimangono wallet
molto rovente tutti quelli che hanno
comprato
bitcoin in questa sala ha fatto tramite
conio o qualcosa del genere c'è molta
diversità fra un bolletino castoria
bene andiamo verso la conclusione quindi
ste benedette cripto valute
e compriamo no ci investiamo no se e
solo se siamo in grado di capirne
sopportarmi rischi si chiama educazione
finanziaria
in altre parole se abbiamo la
consapevolezza di ciò che facciamo se
passiamo dal palcoscenico dei facili
guadagni alla realtà autentica di un
nuovo strumento la cripta valute
torno saliamo sul palcoscenico delle
cripte valute ci stiamo alla larga
dipende dalla consapevolezza con cui
affrontare la scelta così è se vi pare
grazie mille
[Applauso]